CHRIS CRALL: Welcome
to today's session
on integrating VM workloads
into Anthos Service Mesh.
I'm Chris Crall.
I'm a Product Manager
in Google Cloud.
I've been with Google
for about six years,
and I've been focusing on
services most of that time.
And for the last two
years, specifically
on Anthos Service Mesh.
SVEN MAWSON: And
I'm Sven Mawson.
I'm a Software Engineer
in Google Cloud.
I'm one of the founders
of the Istio project.
And I've been focused really on
expanding the reach of meshes
to multiple clusters and,
in this case, to VMs.
CHRIS CRALL: So before we get
into the details of how we're
integrating VM workloads
into Service Mesh,
I want to give a
little background
and a little motivation
on why we're doing it.
So one of the factors behind
this is the microservice trend.
This is a big topic
in the industry.
It has been for some time.
And people talk about a lot
of things about microservices,
how when you break the
monolithic application up
into smaller services,
your teams can move faster.
They can even decide
which language
each team wants to write in.
Some might write in Java.
Some might write in Python.
It doesn't matter because
they're broken apart
and operate
independently over APIs.
They can roll out new
versions on their own.
They don't need to roll out the
whole application at one time.
It might be more scalable.
They can swap out something
that has been purpose-built
for maybe a SaaS service.
So there are tons of benefits
behind microservices.
But the bottom line is
what you're trying to do
is roll out new solutions
for your customers.
You're trying to get those
solutions out there faster
and make them
better, either higher
reliability, more functionality.
Whatever it is, you're
trying to roll out solutions
to your customers.
However, this new architecture
comes with some drawbacks
as well, right?
As you break things apart,
and now your services
are doing a lot
more communication
than they used to.
So you have to know how
they're communicating.
You may need to secure
that communication.
Since the services
are independent,
then you may have them
logging in different places.
So it's harder to debug.
So all these things can lead to
some confusion, some downtime,
and ultimately,
unhappy customers.
So what can we do to solve this?
Well, one thing we can do
is introduce a service mesh.
Now a service mesh, I've
defined here in generic terms.
And it provides
several attributes.
One is, first off, it
should be transparent.
It should allow us to roll out
a mesh and not have to go in
and change application code.
So you don't have to link in
libraries and things like that.
As we talked about
with microservices,
it should be
language-independent.
So it shouldn't matter
whether your component
is written in Go or Java.
It should work in
the service mesh.
And then you want
that service mesh
to be able to automate a
bunch of things for you.
Whether it's network traffic
or logging or whatever it is,
it should be automatic.
So those are the kinds of things
a service mesh can give you.
So let's talk about
the Anthos Service Mesh
and what it does
provide for you.
Now, Anthos Service
Mesh-- and sometimes,
we use the acronym ASM--
is built on top of Istio.
It's powered by Istio,
which is an open source
project that Google started.
And it works with
multiple partners.
We talk about three
main attributes
of Anthos Service Mesh.
The first thing is
uniform observability.
So the idea is that
we can collect metrics
on all communication
going on in the mesh.
We know which
services are talking
to which other services.
We know what the
requests per second
are between those services.
We can find the error rates.
And that can be done just
instantaneously as well as
over a time series.
We can even set SLOs, both
on availability and latency.
So we have lots of
information about
what is going on in the mesh
from a traffic perspective.
Second, we have
operational agility.
So we are in the network.
And we can control
that network traffic.
So we can do lots of things.
We can do canary deployments,
or blue-green deployments.
We can do load balancing.
And we can do load balancing
with a variety of algorithms.
For testing
purposes, we can even
do fault injections so you can
make sure your services are
resilient.
And we can even set quotas.
The third attribute is security.
So first, we have identities
for the different services.
And with those identities,
we can get certificates.
Once we have those certificates,
then we can enable mTLS.
So with mTLS, now we
know which services
are talking to which services in
a secure cryptographic manner.
And all of the data
can be encrypted
across the connection, so nobody
else can see what's going on.
With mTLS, then,
on top of that, we
can set access control policies.
We have simple things
like allow and deny lists,
but we have lots of other
access control policies as well.
So these are the three big
areas of Anthos Service Mesh.
So let's talk about how
that plays with VMs now.
So we've known from
the very beginning
that VMs were critical in the
service mesh because 80% to 90%
of the workloads in a
customer environment
are running on VMs or
bare metal machines.
Containers in Kubernetes provide
a lot of wonderful benefits.
But again, most of the workloads
are still running on VMs,
so it's critical we integrate
those into the environment.
In this diagram, I'm showing
a high-level architecture
of what the mesh looks like.
So on the left is a
Kubernetes cluster.
And there are some control
plane components running there,
mainly the Istio
sidecar injector,
which puts proxies beside the
pods for the services running
in the cluster.
Across the bottom, I'm also
representing managed control
plane components.
These are Stackdriver
for logging and metrics,
Traffic Director for
controlling the traffic,
and the mesh CA
for certificates.
But in the middle are the VMs.
And again, this is what
this session is about,
is how we incorporate
these VMs into this mesh.
Now, there are a
variety of reasons
that workloads are on VMs.
In some cases, that's just
where they need to run.
Databases have been tuned
and run very well on VMs.
Moving those to
containers may or may not
give you the same
kind of performance.
So a lot of times,
I see customers
that are still running
their data stores in VMs.
And it makes a lot of sense.
Second, we have
packaged applications.
So some vendors don't
support their applications
running in containers.
So this particular
company may have
a ERP or a CRM application.
And they have to run in on a VM.
In fact, usually, the
vendor will tell them
exactly what distro and
what version of the VM
they have to run.
Most importantly,
though, are probably
the legacy applications.
These are the
applications that you've
built to run your business.
And those are still
running on VMs.
They probably will
be for a long time.
There's no way that a company
has the budget, the time,
and the engineers to move
everything over to containers,
even if that made sense.
So VMs are going to be
around for a long time.
They're the majority
of the workload.
And we have to incorporate
those into the mesh.
So let's start diving into
how we're going to do that.
And we're going to talk about
managed instance groups.
Now, managed instance
groups are a feature of GCE.
And they are a set of VMs
that all look the same
and run the same
kind of workload.
So for example, if you
have a web front end,
you might want 10 VMs
running that web front end.
You might even
want to autoscale.
You're doing load
balancing, things like that.
So the way that managed instance
groups are created in GCE
is you first create
a instance template.
Now, this template defines
what the VM looks like.
How much memory do I want?
How cores chords do I want?
What kind of storage, what
kind of persistent disks
I want, what network the
VMs are going to run on--
all of those things go
in the instance template.
Once they're in there,
the managed instance group
is created.
And the user tells
the management group
how many VMs should be created.
I want 20 VMs, or I
want a hundred VMs.
Or you can even do autoscaling--
I want somewhere
between 15 and 35 VMs.
So the managed instance
group will spin up the VMs
and control how they're created.
The wonderful
thing about MIGs is
because that managed
instance group is controlling
the lifecycle, it can do
health checks on the VMs
and kill VMs that
aren't working correctly
and then restart them.
Again, autoscaling events-- if
you have autoscaling turned on,
it will start and stop the
VMs depending on the load.
So what we're doing--
and Sven will go into a
lot more detail on this--
is we're adding some features
to the instance template
so that when the managed
instance group creates VMs,
it adds the mesh
software to them
and allows them
to join the mesh.
So Sven is going to go
into more detail now.
SVEN MAWSON: So I'm
going to try to give
a brief overview of the
architecture of the system.
And I'm going to use an example
that we're actually going
to be using in a demo later.
So here, we have a GKE cluster
that's running Anthos Service
Mesh 1.6.
And it has the online
boutique sample application
installed in it.
But we actually took out
the product catalog service,
and we moved that
over into a MIG
instead of being run
in a Kubernetes pod.
And I want to talk a little
bit about how Anthos Service
Mesh works and the
services it relies on,
because I think it's important
to understand just how
many different services are
involved in making the mesh
actually work the
way you want to.
So the first thing that
happens when the MIG starts up
is that it starts
up this agent that's
running in the MIG in the VM.
And that agent connects
over to the DNS server
running in Kubernetes,
KubeDNS, and acts
as a proxy for that DNS server.
And this is used to give
service discovery to the VM
just like you get service
discovery in pods.
So the same type
of mesh services
will be resolved to IP
addresses in that mesh.
The second service
it talks to is
the mesh CA, which is used to
mint certificates for the VM.
And the way that this
works in practice
is that the agent is actually
acting kind of as a proxy.
So it runs a secret
discovery service
that that proxy can connect to.
And it proxies that
over to the mesh CA.
And it gets the CA
certificates from there.
So the agent then starts
up the Envoy proxy
that's running inside the VM.
And the proxy is configured
to talk to the control plane
component.
And in this picture, it's
Istiod running in the cluster.
And it's also configured to send
telemetry over to Stackdriver.
So this sends all of the logs,
metrics, traces, and actually
also edges, which we use
for our topology graph
over to Stackdriver.
And it, of course,
connects to the agent
for those certificates so it
can get mutual TLS bootstrapped.
The application itself is then
proxied via that Envoy proxy.
And that can be done
one of two ways.
It's either using IP tables,
which is a transparent proxy
mechanism, or it
can actually also
be run at white box mode,
where the application knows
about the proxy and sort of
manually interacts with it.
ASM is also relying on
the Kubernetes API server
for configuration storage.
That's actually
not pictured here.
But that's also another key
component of the system.
You need a place to store
your configuration, things
like service definitions,
authorization policies,
the routing information.
Basically, all the
configuration for the features
that Anthos Service
Mesh offers is provided
in that configurations drawing.
So let's walk through
how we actually
add this MIG to the mesh.
And we're going to look at
the four different steps here.
So step 1 is configuring
the VM's identity.
Step 2 is starting up
the MIG and connecting it
to the services it needs.
And then steps 3 and 4
are registering that VM
as an endpoint in the mesh and
selecting that endpoint, or all
the endpoints that are relevant,
into relevant services.
So let's walk through
them one by one.
So the first thing
we're going to look at
is the identity space.
And this gets a
little bit complicated
because, on GCP,
the VMs are actually
running as GCP service
accounts, not as
Kubernetes service accounts.
And these have a different form.
So a GCP service account--
there's really two different
main ways that you'd run a VM.
You can either use the
default service account
for the VM, which is just
project-number-compute.
Or you can use a named service
account that you created,
which is a
service-account-name@project-id.
And these would be the
identity that the VM starts up
with and is available through
the metadata server built
into GCE.
But in Anthos Service Mesh, we
want to use mesh identities.
So mesh identities are
basically three parts.
They are a trust domain,
or a workload pool,
which identifies the
source of the identities.
And then there are a namespace
and a service account
within that namespace.
And so we need to map
between these two.
And ASM for GCE provides
a default mapping
that will map those
service accounts from GCP
over into service
accounts in Anthos.
We are also working on making
this configurable so you
can map into the
namespaces that you want to
rather than using
the default mapping
if that doesn't work for you.
OK, so now we need to actually
get that instance group started
and verify that everything
is actually working.
So we do this using the
mechanisms that Chris was just
talking about earlier.
We use an instance template that
we configure with the service
proxy.
We give it the configuration.
It needs to know what
entity it needs to use.
And then we connect it to
the control plane components
that I was just talking about.
Once it's running, we can
verify that it works correctly.
We can check that it's
connected to the control plane,
and it's getting configuration.
We can verify it
has a certificate,
and rotation is set up properly.
And we can make sure that
telemetry is going over
to Stackdriver and even go and
actually look at that telemetry
if we want to in
Stackdriver to make sure it
looks like what we expect.
So we have this running, But
we aren't able to actually call
the VM yet.
So we can't route
traffic to it yet.
So to get traffic to the
VM, we need to register.
And in Anthos Service
Mesh, we do this
through a decoupling
mechanism that's
very similar to how pods and
services work in Kubernetes.
The equivalent in Anthos
Service Mesh for VMs
is WorkloadEntry
and ServiceEntry.
And a WorkloadEntry is
basically a named endpoint
in a namespace.
It gives us a way to attach
labels and attach a service
account to an endpoint.
And then that thing
can be selected
by the next thing we're
going to talk about,
which is a ServiceEntry.
So a ServiceEntry basically
lets us create named mappings
to endpoints in the
same way that you
do with Kubernetes services,
except that it can also
select workload entries.
So just like a
Kubernetes service,
it has a port, or a
set of ports, actually.
It has a workload
selector that says
what endpoints are selected.
And in ASM, we also let
you specify the host
as a generic opaque string.
It doesn't have to just
be a Kubernetes service.
We can actually use
other types too.
But for using the same
service as a Kubernetes one,
you can just specify the
host, like we did here.
So that's how this all
works and the architecture.
Let's look at a demo next.
So in the demo,
we're actually going
to set up exactly the
architecture I just
talked about.
And we're going to show off the
three pillars of Anthos Service
Mesh, the observability
features, the agility,
networking, and traffic
management features,
and the security features.
So we'll look at each of
those in turn in this demo.
So let's see our demo of VMs
running with Anthos Service
Mesh.
So in this demo, we're going
to show the three main pillars
of Anthos Service Mesh, the
observability features here
in the form of the dashboards,
the traffic management
capabilities, which
we're going to show
a little bit of canarying
of a new version,
and the security features.
And here, we're going to
show authorization policies.
And this just gives
you a little flavor
of what you can do with
Anthos Service Mesh for VMs.
It's not meant to be a complete
demo of all the good things you
get from it.
So let's get into it.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is look at what we
have created so far.
So we have a cluster
here, a GKE cluster,
running Anthos Service Mesh.
This cluster also has the online
boutique sample application
installed, except we don't have
the product catalog service.
So we're also running a
managed instance group
with two VMs in it.
And they are running
the product catalog
service for the online
boutique instead
of running it in clusters.
So this can show you how
you can run VMs combined
with your Kubernetes services.
But right now, we don't
have these things hooked up
together.
So right now, this is failing
because the mesh doesn't
know about this VM.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is actually show that
registration step.
So we're going create
a WorkloadEntry
and a ServiceEntry for the VMs.
So let's look at these.
So this is a WorkloadEntry
for the product catalog
service, V1 of it,
running on an IP address.
So let's go ahead and create it.
And let's also look at
the ServiceEntry for this.
And this ServiceEntry basically
says the product catalog
service is all of the workload
entries with the label selected
below, where the app is
product catalog service.
So this will select everything,
and it's not actually
used in the version.
We'll see what version
is used for later.
And this is basically the
same as a Kubernetes service
except it can select workload
entries as well as Kubernetes
pods.
So let's go ahead
and create that.
And now that we've created
that, our online boutique
should be working again.
And there it is.
It's working.
So once we have this up and
running, the first thing we get
is all the telemetry features.
So the telemetry--
because there's
load going through this
service, all that telemetry
is going to Stackdriver.
And we can actually see it
in the Anthos Service Mesh
dashboard.
So here's the dashboard for
the product catalog service.
We can see the requests per
second, error rates, latencies,
CPU usage, things like that.
You can also use all
the other great features
of Anthos Service
Mesh dashboards,
the Health ability to create a
SLOs, look at detailed metrics,
look at connected services,
do more diagnostics,
that kind of stuff.
So all the same
features you expect,
but now available for a
service running in a VM.
So the next step is, let's
do some traffic management.
So we want to roll
out V2 of our service.
And the only
difference in V1 and V2
is we're going to have a
slightly different product
catalog in this case.
We're going to have
different product
description and a different
price for this typewriter.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So the way we do
this is we're going
to create another WorkloadEntry.
And here, we use V2 as
the version instead of V1.
And otherwise, it's the same.
And we don't have to actually
change the ServiceEntry.
We just add a new WorkloadEntry,
which is basically
adding a new endpoint.
So let's create that.
And then we also need
to create a destination
rule and a virtual service.
So let's look at our destination
rule, which actually we're
already running.
So this destination
rule just says
that there's two subsets to
the product catalog service.
There's a V1 and a V2.
And those are selected based
on V1 and V2 labels, so very
simple.
And let's do a traffic split.
So let's split traffic
50-50 between these.
Now, normally, you'd want
to do, like, a 1% or 0.1%
or something very,
very small when
you're canarying your
version, but here, we just
want to show that it works.
We're just going to
go to straight 50%.
And now if we go back to our
typewriter, if we refresh,
we should be able
to see-- yep, there
it is-- a different version.
So the product
description changed.
The price changed.
It went up a lot.
New version, more
expensive typewriters.
And if you keep
refreshing, you can
see sometimes it'll going
to V1, sometimes go to V2.
It just basically is flipping a
coin and deciding between them.
So let's say we're
happy with that,
and we decide, yep, let's
actually go full-on V2.
So we can do that.
We have a virtual
service that says,
yes, send it all to subset V2.
And let's apply that.
And now if we go
to our boutique,
our typewriter should
always be on V2.
So that's a really
basic look at some
of the network capabilities.
Now let's look at our
final area here, security.
And so we already have
mTLS set up, right?
So these services
are all talking
to each other over mTLS.
They each have an identity.
They have certificates.
They're all set up.
But we're not actually
preventing any access.
As long as something has a
certificate, it gets through.
And so what we want to
do is be able to say,
only the services we expect
to be calling are allowed to.
So what we use is ASM's
authorization policy
to do this.
And first, what
we're going to do
is show an authorization
policy that
just locks it down completely.
So that's a good first
step, although, clearly, you
don't want to do this
production directly.
But we can deny all traffic to
this product catalog service.
And so all we have to do is
create an authorization policy.
It has a selector that matches
that product catalog service,
but it has new rules.
So it doesn't allow any traffic.
It just denies it all.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Once we deny everything, if
we go look at our boutique,
it gives an access denied error,
which is what we'd expect.
So what about actually allowing
the traffic that we do want?
Well, so here, we
have a different rule.
This is, again, very simple.
We have a rule that just
says, if the principle that
is calling is the default
service account in the shop
namespace, let it through,
and block everything else.
So let's go ahead
and apply that one.
And now if we go look at
our shop, it works again.
And so that is
basically what security
looks like for Anthos
Service Mesh with VMs.
And so between that and
the traffic management
that you get from
Anthos Service Mesh
and the great
observability features,
you can see just
how useful this can
be for using virtual machines
with Anthos Service Mesh.
Thanks.
CHRIS CRALL: Thanks, Sven.
That was a great demo.
But I have a couple of questions
I've received from customers.
The first one is, what
about a single VM?
How do I handle that?
SVEN MAWSON: Well, so the
great thing about MIGs,
aside from all the great
features they offer,
is that, actually, they're free.
So you can just take
your VM, and you
can extract an
image from it, which
GCP makes very easy to do.
And you can run that as a single
VM in a single managed instance
group.
And again, that's free.
There's no extra
charge for that.
And it's very easy to do.
And then you can get all
the great features of MIGs,
including the ability
to run and manage them.
CHRIS CRALL: OK.
And this is all great on GCE.
But I have Anthos
on-prem, and I want
to integrate my on-prem VMs.
How do I do that?
SVEN MAWSON: So we
are actively working
on making that both supported
and very, very easy.
It won't be quite as easy as
we've managed to make it on GCE
because we don't have the
equivalent of managed instance
groups.
But we do have plans
in place to release
a version of Anthos Service
Mesh with VM support
for on prem, where you take
a couple more steps than what
we've outlined here.
You would be responsible
for generating
the configuration
that goes on the VM
and installing the
HMM proxy there.
And we provide
packages to do that.
But then once you have
that, everything else
will be the same
as described here.
You can set up
the same features.
It connects to the control
plane the same way.
And you get all the great Anthos
Service Mesh capabilities.
CHRIS CRALL: OK.
And one last question--
what if I have just VMs?
My department or division isn't
using Kubernetes right now.
I just have VMs.
How do I set up the
mesh with those?
SVEN MAWSON: So that is
a excellent question.
So during the
architecture overview
that I was giving
earlier, I was talking
a little bit about
the different services
that we need to connect to.
And so three of those
services were still
running in the cluster.
So there was the
Istiod control plane.
There was the
KubeDNS DNS resolver.
And there was the API server
used for configuration storage.
And the great news is
we're working on managed
versions of all of those.
So the control plane,
the managed version,
is Traffic Director,
which is already
available through GCP's APIs.
And we're working on making
it available through Anthos
Service Mesh.
For DNS, we're actively
working with the Cloud DNS team
to actually integrate the
Kubernetes DNS serving
and GCE's DNS serving
into a single system.
So actually, that
will all be built in.
You won't need to
do anything extra.
And again, it'll be a
completely managed service.
And then, finally, we're
working on making it a managed
version of the API server.
So again, you don't
need to run anything.
You can just use the
managed API server
and use VMs with all of those
components fully managed
by Google.
CHRIS CRALL: Great.
OK, well, thank you very much.
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah,
great questions.
And this was a lot of fun.
Thanks very much.